باستخدام مستشعر درجة الحرارة الجديد في
Apple watch series 8 ، يمكنك الآن الحصول
على تقدير بأثر رجعي
للوقت الذي قمت فيه بالإباضة لدورة متقدمة أخرى ، حيث يمكن الآن إخطار جميع المستخدمين على نظام التشغيل iOS 16 ويمكن الآن إخطار watchos 9
بانحرافات الدورة المحتملة ، وإمكانية
استشعار درجة الحرارة في
السلسلة 8 بالإضافة إلى القلب  تجتمع بيانات دورة المعدل والسجل
معًا لتوفر
لك عرضًا تفصيليًا لدورتك ولديك
تحكم دقيق في أنواع البيانات
التي تشاركها والأشخاص الذين تشاركها مع
[الموسيقى] ،
وقد تم تصميم كل التفاصيل
لإنشاء أكثر تفاحة صلابة وقدرة
الساعة تبدأ من أي وقت مضى مع علبة
مصنوعة من التيتانيوم من الدرجة الفضائية والتي
تحقق التوازن المثالي بين
متانة الوزن ومقاومة التآكل
، وتمتد علبة التيتانيوم لأعلى
لتحيط بلورة الياقوت المسطحة الأمامية
لحمايتها من تأثيرات الحافة التي يمكن أن
تحدث أثناء الأنشطة الشديدة
وفي المركز  من العلبة مقاس 49 ملم هي
أكبر شاشة لدينا سطوعًا على الإطلاق في
ساعة
أبل  نقاط طريق بوصلة es لتحديد
موقع مثل موقع رأس الممر
أو خيمتك
ويمكن إضافتها بسرعة
باستخدام زر الحركة
أخيرًا تم تصميم Apple watch Ultra
للرياضات المائية ويمكنها
تحمل القوى الديناميكية الشديدة
للأنشطة مثل ركوب الأمواج بالطائرة الورقية و
wakeboarding apple watch series 8 مع
الكشف عن الأعطال ومستشعر درجة الحرارة
الذي يمكّن ميزات صحة المرأة الجديدة
في تصميم يحبه المستخدمون
، وأخيراً
Apple watch Ultra لدينا أكثر
ساعة أبل قدرة حتى الآن